- [Inae] I like making food item as a cake
because it's a really
easy to make to be real.
(upbeat music)
Hi, I'm Inae.
I'm an illusion cake artist.
Today, we're going to make
fast food burger cake.
This is cherry cake batter.
Adding some oil.
Adding some milk.
Whisk until you don't see any cake crumbs.
And I'm going to add cherries.
The eggs.
Mix it really good.
Mix until you don't see any eggs.
Going to add a little bit
of red food coloring to it.
I picked red and yellow
because McDonald's has red and yellow.
This reminds me of Halloween.
It's my favorite holiday.
I have lemon cake batter already mixed.
Going to add.
A little bit of oil.
You can use whisk or a spatula.
Just want to make it really nice.
I'm going to add lemon juice.
Then you can also add a little
bit a yellow food coloring.
Okay, so I'm going to
pour lemon cake batter.
This cake batter looks
like ketchup and mustard
(laughing)
And I love it.
Spread into a pan.
Cherry cake goes into pans.
(upbeat music)
Spread it really nice.
And I usually go tap tap tap.
(pan tapping)
(upbeat music)
I'm going to carve this cake.
It looks like burger buns.
First, I'm going to use cutter.
Then I'm going to carve it.
All right, this is done.
And this is going to be my bottom.
The bottom one is not as round as top one
because the bottom one is more flat.
Cut just a little bit on top
and then flip upside down.
And this is going to be my bottom bun.
Time to make cake pops.
We just need one scoop of buttercream,
and then mix really good
with the cake crumbs.
So this lemon cake is
going to be two patties
for the cake burger.
And I'm going to put this in the fridge
so that it gets a little sturdy.
Frosting time.
So I made this beautiful
cream cheese frosting,
and I like to use this plastic
scraps to make it smooth.
Okay, I'm going to put it in the fridge.
Okay, here is my lemon cake pop.
I'm going to frost with chocolate ganache.
And this is for the burger patty.
Okay, it looks like a patty already.
We have top bun.
And I'm going to use modeling chocolate
to cover this bun.
Corn starch to sprinkle on the table
so that modeling chocolate
doesn't stick on the table.
And I use a rolling pin to make
chocolate a little thinner.
(upbeat music)
And use a cutter to cut the
excess of modeling chocolate.
Going to cut it.
Tuck in little more.
Then I like to press some lines
so that it doesn't look
like perfectly round
because all buns doesn't look same.
Okay, here's my patty.
I would like to cover with
the modeling chocolate
with little bit of brown food coloring
so that it matches patty color.
Sprinkle cornstarch.
Make sure it doesn't stick on the table.
(upbeat music)
And I would like to use this piece of foil
to create the texture of a patty.
Sometimes I like to use everything
I can find in my kitchen
or just my house.
And this foil will make
perfect texture of a patty.
I'm going to airbrush the top bun.
And this is food coloring.
I mixed with a brown,
orange, and yellow color.
(upbeat music)
(spraying)
I'm going to paint patty
with edible food paint.
I use regular paintbrush
from regular art store.
(upbeat music)
I went to culinary school in the city.
I was watching TV and "Cake Boss" was on.
It seemed like, oh, I think I can do that.
But I have no idea what they're using.
So I started to search.
They have this one-day program
that you make a birthday cake.
I went there, I made a birthday cake,
and it turned out really good.
It was first time I ever baked cake.
(laughing)
I'm going to paint a little bit of glaze
to look more juicy looking patty.
I'm going to sprinkle some sugar.
Patty's done.
This is a gelatin, and
it's going to be onion.
And I'm chopping onions.
No, actually gelatin.
(laughing)
I made a white chocolate ganache
and add that a bit of
red and orange coloring.
Looks like Big Mac sauce.
And I'll mix together
with my gelatin onion.
I'm using wafer paper to make lettuce.
So first, I'm going to petal
dust with a green color.
Randomly spread it.
Cut little pieces.
(tearing)
Spray water.
Put it on the mold.
This mold is for flower petal.
Just give a little bit of texture.
And you can kind of just rip it.
And looks like lettuce.
We're going to make American cheese.
I'm using modeling chocolate.
Sprinkle lit bit of
cornstarch before I mix it.
Yellow modeling chocolate,
a little bit of red.
(upbeat music)
Ta-dah, yay.
Okay, let's make a pickle.
I'm using modeling chocolate.
So I like to use this serrated
knife for the edge of pickle.
Just cutting it.
And then I use this tool to
make a little bit more pickley.
See?
Easy.
Then, I would like to give
a little bit of texture
on pickle too.
Let's paint it.
I feel like there is no between.
Either you like pickle
or you don't like pickle.
(laughing)
Okay, it's done.
Pickle.
Time to build a burger.
I'm putting cream cheese
frosting between bun and patty.
Cheese time.
(dramatic music)
This is Big Mac sauce.
That's really chunky.
Add some lettuce.
I like to have a model
when I paint something real
so I can get exact color and texture.
(upbeat music)
We want to put middle bun.
We just need a tiny bit
of cheese at the end
because we just going to see the edge.
Some pickles.
I personally love pickles.
So I'm going to put extra pickles.
More lettuce.
(dramatic music)
I'm using modeling chocolate
to make tiny Sesame seeds.
And I'm using torch to make
sauce look more runny looking.
Then I'm going to use a
little bit of glaze on pickle
because pickle always has water.
Okay, it's done.
(upbeat music)
That's assembled Big Mac cake.
Let's cut it and see what happens.
(upbeat music)
That's the completed
fast food hamburger cake.
Thank you for watching.
Let us know what you guys think.
(upbeat music)
- [Man] Oh yes!